[Music]
my favorite programming hack in python
is that
you can overload functions um
with the at sign
by overriding its matrix multiplication
meta method i really like ternary
operators i don't know why but every
time i use one
it makes me feel smart and it makes my
code look elegant so i try to use them
wherever possible
pdb like the python debugger and being
able to stop
your program state at any point in time
and then like simulate what what could
have happened if you wrote other code
instead i think super useful like it
makes deep learning interactive
debugging it's like fantastic
well this is more like a library that's
very very common in uh people that use
machine learning it's called tqdm it's a
it's very simple it's just a progress
indicator
but once you start using uh like
training these large models you'll just
realize just how useful it is to have
that little progress bar
um showing you how far your model has
gone with training and uh evaluation too
one powerful feature of matlab is that
you can use a matrix operations so
instead of working with numbers
individually you can
put them in a matrix put them in vectors
and
do processes on them at once and it's
really powerful because um this tool is
really optimized for working with
matrices really fast so you can get
things done match up much faster
i don't know if it's a hack or what but
i can never remember
which way the matrices go in matrix
multiplication right it's just you have
no idea what's going on in a matrix
multiplication
and and sometimes it's just hard to
think about so instead of matrix
multiplying you can use the einstein
summation operator and this allows you
to explicitly state like what's going
into the matrix multiply how it's
combining on the axes and how it gets
summed up and a lot of people don't like
the einstein summation but i'm a i'm an
einstein summation zealot that i i use
all time saves me a ton of mental
overhead and i never have to remember
how the matrices fit together ever again
[Music]
you